est-ce que ça sentirait pas un petit peu
la fin de l'année clairement on s'en
rapproche tout doucement et comme chaque
fin d'année bien je vous adresse émail
juste pas pour le père noël pas pour
vous acheter des cadeaux plupart de
malmaison banon ma liste de produits que
j'ai aimé tout au long de cette année
que je vais vous recommander pour cette
fin d'année c'est ma sélection pour la
fin de l'année alors une sélection qui
aura aussi bien pour le black friday qui
ira aussi bien pour renault el khir
aussi bien pour l'anniversaire de
grandes papin grand tata ou grands
tendon qui tombe le 15 décembre est ma
sélection de produits de l'année que
j'ai aimé et dont je vais vous faire
part aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat catamarca innova
qui me permet de vous présenter deux
produits de bons plans super intéressant
si vous chercher les solutions de
recharge alors la première c'est celle
là c'est le sirius 65 watts et un
chargeur universel pour ordinateurs
portables et pour smartphones ça c'est
chargeur universel 65 watts le plus
petit le plus puissant le plus
écologique également si vous voulez les
brancher dans une prise électrique bien
vous le prenez vous le positionner comme
ça vous le mettez dans une prise murale
voyez ça vous fera un petit truc hyper
discret si vous voulez mettre dans une
multiprise vous allez vous dire que là
vous allez venir galéré donc vous
l'enlever et vous venez le poser comme
ça et là il va se poser à la verticale
dans une multiprise ce qui fait que vous
avez un vrai gain de place en plus vous
avez un cap qui est super grand on à 93%
d'efficience énergétique grâce à une
techno qui s'appelle échos volta ce qui
est breveté par électronique avec
lucerne 65 watts des poires me recharger
un macbook un smartphone également une
tablette est pas un appareil
électronique compatible power délivre
ici vous intéresse le lien et thomas de
la description et le coût de 99 euros 90
et on a ensuite un deuxième produit qui
va aussi vous plaît ça c'est une power
banque qui vous servira à venir charger
plusieurs appareils signée apple vous
avez déjà un bouton pour venir l'allumé
pour éteindre vous voyez le niveau de
batterie restant vous le recharger par
ici en usb c'est surtout vous rechargez
avec votre cyrus 65 watts comme ça vous
voulez charger vos appareils vont lui
même chargé votre powerbook nous poser
votre un peu le match elle va surcharger
vous prenez votre iphone vous le posez
au centre il vient charger et vous
prenez vos airpod ever podz vont
également chargé comme ça vous venir
charger trois appareils apple
extrêmement facilement et en plus de ça
vous avez un premier câble en usb c'est
vers lightning vous venez recharger
également en usb c'est vers usb c'est
vous avez m un adaptateur usb c'est vers
usb que vous voulez mettre comme ça ici
vous pouvez venir recharger déjà trois
appareils sans fil plus un autre
appareil filaire que ce soit un iphone
que ce soit 1 ordinaire or puisque vous
avez intérieur une batterie de 10000
milliampères heures avec 53 watts de
puissance totale en sortie et la power
marque coûte 149 euros il ya également
un bundle qui existe l'apple power
bundle qui regroupe la pauvre ben mais
également le sirius 65 watts au tarif de
230 euros et vous avez également un code
promo profiter de 15% de remise avec le
code monsieur 15 tout est en bas dans la
description donc cette sélection la
soeur ou plusieurs parties mais avoir
effectivement une grosse partie
smartphone parce que ça reste le coeur
de ma chaîne essaie des produits j'ai
beaucoup testé on va se parler également
d'autres dieux on va se parler de
produits connectés pour la maison va se
parler aussi un petit peu de caméras on
va se parler de pas mal de choses vous
allez voir c'est assez complet c'est
super intéressant ce ne sont que des
produits que j'ai testé des produits que
j'ai vu alors il a fallu faire un choix
c'était très très très compliqué de
demander de faire un choix là dessus
parce que tu t'étais des stones de
produits il y en a plein que j'ai
beaucoup aimé d'autres que j'ai moins
aimé et j'ai pas pu mettre tous les
produits même ceux que j'ai beaucoup
aimé il a fallu faire un choix on va
commencer tout de suite par les
smartphones avant les smartphones on va
commencer tout de suite parlé les tarifs
les plus bas pour monter aux tarifs les
plus hauts sur les tarifs les plus bas
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup aimé le
chiffre nul aurait minutes 10 alors j'ai
beaucoup aimé pas parce que
technologiquement c'est un truc de
dingue dingue non mais parce qu'en fait
c'est un super rapport qualité prix en
termes de photos vous avez parlé très
très loin sur le capteur principal vous
ferez du taf le reste c'est pas
extraordinaire mais vous avez
suffisamment ce qu'il faut pour avoir un
smartphone qui fonctionne à moins de 200
euros on peut jouer à des jeux on peut
faire des photos on peut prendre des
applications tant mieux ça fonctionnera
bref moins de 200 mal c'est un très bon
rapport qualité prix signifie au mieux
ça marche bien le poteau x3 pro soucier
un produit que j'ai beaucoup aimé alors
là on est pareil en dessous des 300
euros cette fois ci le pot quand il sera
prêt il était intéressant pour tous
khaled gaming la performance brute la
photo il est pas terrible si vous voulez
juste un smartphone peut faire la photo
c'est pas le pot cox trois pros qu'il
vous faudra qu'il fera des photos mais
elles sont pas dingue des par contre ont
joué en termes de performance vous avez
un super rapport qualité prix à moins de
300 euros une fois qu'ils seront
extrêmement intéressant et je vous dis
tout de suite tous les produits dont je
vous parlais liens sont en bas dans la
description il ya ensuite le rythme pro
alors il me fait un peu le challenger de
xiaomi sont un peu en face à face sur
les produits qui viennent proposer je
trouve intéressant le riz 2008 pro en
termes de performance je trouve en fait
assez équilibré en termes de
performances en termes de photos en un
capteur sans 8 mégapixels on est dans la
série 7 de qualcomm on n'a pas un truc
qui est dingue dingue mais qui marche
pas mais vraiment pas mal et je trouve
assez intéressant on va ensuite monté en
termes de prix on n'arrive plus dans le
milieu de gamme produit qui est super
intéressant très équilibré qui est pour
moi le milieu de gamme pas presque
parfait mais vraiment bien conçu c'est
le samsung galaxy à 52 s 5g plutôt bon
photos plutôt bons termes de
performances on a ce qu'il faut sous le
capot ça fonctionnera parfaitement est
un smartphone qui est très équilibré
donc si vous voulez un smartphone milieu
de gamme qui fait tout autant faire trop
samsung galaxy à 52 s 5 g on va ensuite
avoir le honor 50 alors l'honneur cinq
ans j'ai testé ya pas longtemps et je le
mets dans la liste parce que je trouve
intéressant on a le retour des services
google chine au nord seuls smartphones
qui est honnête qui est qoreï qui coûte
à peu près 500 euros et qui fonctionnera
bien ensuite à notre production serait
pas mal c'est au port et no 6 le réno 6
on est un petit peu moins de 500 euros
également lauriers il rénos histoire et
nos six pros moi j'ai préféré le leur et
no 6 il en fait un peu moins que le
promet un petit peu moins de 500 euros
je trouve vraiment vraiment en est super
rapport qualité prix sera pas mal en
photo la vidéo c'est un peu moins ça
elle est par mon test si vous voulez
tout savoir sur ce smartphone là surtout
il al'avantage d'avoir l'expérience
logiciel de au pot qui est vraiment très
très bonne on peut customiser beaucoup
de choses se soient la taille des icônes
les formes et compagnie bref c'est
vraiment complet et ça marche vraiment
bien on monte ensuite en prix on arrive
avec le wild +9 alors j'aurais pu vous
dire le one + 9 prob il était un petit
peu moins de 1000 euros et sauf qu'ils
n'étaient pas extrêmement bien
positionnés en termes de tarifs le one +
9 l'est beaucoup plus a à peu près 7 119
euros ça super joli produit il ya eu un
partenariat avec la soul blade au niveau
de la photo il ya eu un bond en avant
qui était au niveau de la photo pour
autant on avait de la performance
derrière on a une très jolie machine
bien équilibrée keira aussi bien pour la
photo pour le gaming très jolie finition
et c'est un produit j'aime beaucoup de
vous recommande note marc j'ai testé
cette année qui était très sympa c'est
le vivre x 60 pro c'est un smartphone
qui est un peu atypique et très sympa
niveau ils ont un système de guimps ball
en fait au niveau de leur caméra ce qui
donne quelque chose de très stabiliser à
ce que vous allez dire faire de la vidéo
et ça c'est pas mal du tout pour autant
c'est pas le smartphone le plus
performant ce n'est pas le smartphone
qui ira le mieux en terme de vidéo mais
ce qu'il propose et bien c'est quand
même vraiment pas mal et là on se situe
un petit peu moins de 700 euros après on
va arriver dans les smartphones j'irai
plus haut de gamme très joli modèle que
j'ai adoré ce talent et c'était le
finepix trois pros alors ça remonte un
peu parce que les sorties en tout début
d'année on était un peu plus de 1000
euros à sa sortie je sais pas combien
était un petit peu moins aujourd'hui
très jolie smartphone qu'on doit pouvoir
commencer à trouver déjà en
reconditionnés le finepix 3po j'avais
beaucoup aimé il était un peu
différenciant très jolie expérience très
bons sauts taux courants vidéographe
très très jolie smartphones après
d'autres produits que j'ai trouvé très
sympa c'est dans la gamme s de samsung
c'est le plus haut de gamme et notamment
le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra lors c'est
un peu facile vous me direz parce que
c'est le plus haut de gamme du plus haut
de gamme certes c'est vrai les moteurs
sont pas mal mais c'est vrai que s-21
ultra il a une petite saveur de vierzy
qui est vraiment pas mal non plus alors
pour autant il faut avoir le budget on a
plus de 1000 euros mais c'est un très
joli smartphone le million ultra il très
cher aussi lyon ultra des très très bon
smartphone très atypique de la
performance très bon photo on fait des
choses vraiment pas mal ça montre tout
le savoir-faire de xiaomi la montée en
gamme qu'ils ont effectués depuis
l'année dernière au niveau de leurs
gammes je vous le cache pas les iphone
13 presse pro 13 pro mag presse quand
même d'excellents smartphones bien
équilibré on est dans autre chose là on
est forcément plus chez android ont des
chiens au est très très très haut les
smartphones de la performance bête de
compet une encoche un peu plus réduite
très très belle proposition il faut
avoir le budget mais si vous voulez un
bon smartphone si vous voulez un bel
iphone iphone 13 13 pro 13 pronax c'est
top et puis j'ai une mention un peu
particulière c'est un coup de coeur
innovation cette année c'est sur le
samsung galaxy z flip 3 très jolis
produits et surtout on se rapproche des
1000 euros et on peut le trouver tout de
suite à l'instant t elle à cacher cette
vidéo est bien un petit peu moins de
1000 euros il pas plus les liens sont en
bas de la description super produit
effet de rapprocher le pli yable du
grand public avec implique
meaney si génial alors après une autre
réflexion c'est un produit dont vous
n'êtes pas sorti de tests que j'ai pris
en main j'ai fait des photos je me suis
baladé un peu avec gégé mis du temps je
peux reconnaître j'aurais peut-être dû
le sortir c'est sur l'xperia wymark 3
alors l'ex paria bonne marque 3 c'est un
produit qui est très intéressant il ya
eu un un vrai gros travail qui a été
fait par sony sur son appareil là la
réflexion sur ce produit est là
continuer à mûrir mon côté surtout ce
que j'ai testé le google pixels six pros
je trouve qu'ils allaient trop loin au
niveau de vue côté optimisation logiciel
qui était un peu flec et je me suis dit
en fait c'est pas con ce qui propose
sony parce que j'ai discuté avec les
équipes de sony notamment en début
d'année je suis pas forcément d'accord
avec ce que vous proposez vous parce que
ce que les gens veulent c'est du pôle it
and shoot on prend un smartphone on fait
une photo on veut pas se prendre la tête
on veut que ça marche bien je continue à
penser ça mais je dirais que l'ex paria
bonne mc3 il intéressant pour toutes les
personnes qui veulent vraiment faire de
la photo sur smartphone de la
photographie et pas juste faire une
photo votre pôle tennis foot donc si
vous voulez un bon photophone qui vous
permettra d'aller chercher dans vos
paramètres d'aller gratter et de ne pas
sortir des trucs aberrant avec des
contre-jours vous voyez très bien des
choses qui n'existent pas en réalité en
photo et bien on se rapprochera vraiment
de l'expérience photographique avec
l'xperia one mark iii ce n'est pas un
smartphone parfait ce n'est pas le
smartphone je pense mais pour le plus
grand public mais si vous êtes amoureux
de photographies que vous recherchez une
expérience photographique sur un
smartphone jeu par la voix de mark iii
et puis pour le gaming une référence
asus rog iphone 5 pas plus pas moins
edel évidemment vos smartphones il faut
penser à venir les protéger notamment
avec les coques de mon partenaire
rhinochill d'un oui parce qu'ils ont des
offres super intéressante du 18 novembre
jusqu'au 1er décembre vous avez jusqu'à
-60% sur tout le site de rhinau chine et
ça c'est très cool et en plus avec le
code greu 21 on vous enlève 10% de
l'addition donc moins 60 et ensuite on
enlève 10% c'est franchement une bonne
affaire et des coques cirino chine y en
a dans tous les univers il ya des
nouvelles collections avec marvel des
collections disney notamment mickey des
collections disney pixels vous on trouve
également dans l'univers de star wars et
vous en avait des tonnes de collection
du nid r pour tout le monde pour tous
les goûts égérie nauche il vous avez
aussi bien des solides suite des coques
que des bols peur des protections
d'écran des câbles vous pouvez protéger
aussi vos airpod vous apple watch vous
pouvez quasiment tous protégés et là un
tarif hyper canon moins 60 moins dix le
code greu 21 grrr 21 et vous avez le
lien bien évidemment en bas dans la
description
alors il ya plein d'autres produits
d'été cette année en dehors des
smartphones on sent un petit passage
rapide par côté caméras caméras d'action
la gopro heroes 10 black très jolis
modèles alors si vous avez une nuit tout
neuf vous changez pas mais si vous avez
un modèle antérieur ou si vous cherchez
une caméra d'action gopro ironise blacks
on va continuer de la mobilité une
trottinette électrique que j'ai testé ya
pas très longtemps s'est lâché au mit
sellami électriques scooters 3 plus de
performances très bons produits les
pneumatiques est vachement bien la route
vous renvoie à ma vidéo parce que c'est
vraiment tout petit c'est très cool donc
si vous cherchez une solution de
mobilité est d'ailleurs trottier de
shlomi vraiment très très bien après on
passe par l'audio alors on nous dit on
va distinguer les casques des écouteurs
en casque une référence que je continue
à citer que j'adore c'est le sonic w/h
melix m3 c'est un casque à quelques
années mais les tarifs ont baissé à 279
euros je trouve toujours très très
actuel et en face vous allez avoir le
dernier casque de bose alors c'est pas
exactement en face parce que en réalité
vous auriez w/h mix m4 et en face vous
aurez le cul c'est 45 de buzz alors
c'est pas le même prix qu ses 45 de buzz
on est à 349 euros 99 c'est un produit
qui est sorti il ya pas très longtemps
que j'ai déjà présenté on a fait un live
ensemble dessus la vraie grosse
différence que vous allez avoir entre
baud et sony c'est que boss et plus du
plug and play et vous prenez vous avez
l'application ça marche tout seul vous
prenez pas la tête faisait pas les
tonnes de paramètres vous pouvez pas
gratter dans sony ces différences au
lycée plus le produit geek très joli
produit super qualité excellente
réduction de bruit active mais vous avez
plein de paramètres plein de trucs à
gratouiller à savoir se chercher une
solution très simple buzz ou si vous
êtes plus geek et vous aimez gratter
sony après en écouteurs j'ai trouvé ça
super intéressant déjà les derniers airs
poels 3 très très bon 199 euros j'avais
été bluffé par la qualité audio nous on
est d'ailleurs déjà parlé en vidéo il ya
les lg tonnes free cfp 9 que j'ai trouvé
très bon à peu près 180 euros j'en ai
également déjà parlé en vidéo dans le
plus haut de gamme on allait sonner wf
1000 x n 4 avec réduction brute active
très très bon surtout plus discret que
l'ex n 3 à 279 euros 99 c'est plutôt le
haut du panier et si on veut beaucoup
moins cher très bon avec une réduction
proactive on n'est pas sur la même
qualité que sony a bien évidemment il ya
vraiment un écart énorme c'est les neuf
thing if one c'est une marque qui
arrivait cette année qui sait créer très
rapidement avec un super produit les
ikhwan à 99 euros et qu'avec bref très
très très jolis produits et en termes de
dieu là dessus à moins de 100 balles
vous serez pas déçus après dans
l'univers monde connecté je veux dire
vous recommander la galaxie watch 3 qui
pour le coup est super intéressante
c'est le nom de samsung parce qu'elle
arrive avec webos intégré adapté
directement pour l'univers samsung et
donc si vous utilisez des produits
google compte google et compagnie et que
vous aimez samsung et l'acsi walsh 3 et
6 e books ont recommandé d'expérience
sur un os ça sera plutôt l'apple watch
est-ce pas forcément là cette lie ce
super rapport qualité-prix côté tablette
on va rester chez apple l'ipad r qui
était présentée l'année dernière on est
quand même à un peu moins de 670 euros
c'est un produit qui est très bon très
actuel il a effectivement un an mais ça
fonctionnera sans aucun problème aux
tablettes trécu sorti cette année s'est
lâché au lycée a pas de 5 399 euros
super rapport qualité prix dans
l'univers de xiaomi un peu moins de 400
euros très jolie tablette et puis une
autre que j'aime bien aussi c'est la
samsung galaxy tab s7 et feux à moins de
600 euros là on se parle de la version
wifi il existe une version 5 g la
version wifi ira très bien fait du
partage de connexion avec vos
smartphones si vous êtes en mobilité
mais n'allez pas acheter la version 5 g
qu'il a coûté plus cher et qui à mon
avis ne servira pas grand chose côté pc
j'ai deux produits qui m'ont vraiment
intéressé cette année alors il ya le
huawei le macbook x vantours 1500 euros
super rapport qualité/prix très joli
produit très belle finition et puis un
produit qui était très atypique est le
asus rog flow ex 13 parce qu'en fait
vous avez deux parties vous avez votre
pc ok et vous avez après une carte
graphique vous rajoutez en extension
alors il faut l'acheter en plus ça coûte
relativement cher mais si vous voulez un
combo pour avoir un pc portable et
l'extension de cartes graphiques pour
faire du gaming top génial puisqu'on est
dans le côté pc on va d'un côté moniteur
j'ai testé le huawei le maïs view je
trouvais très très bon à peu près 500
euros très jolie moniteur une fois de
plus allez jeter un coup d'oeil à la
vidéo parce qu'il est extrêmement cool
et puis un autre que j'ai beaucoup aimé
c'est le samsung smart monitor qui est
un peu moins cher lui on est à 3 170
euros et quelques et l'intérêt du smart
monitor c'est qu'on va pouvoir
l'utiliser comme un moniteur vous
brancher un ordinateur dessus vous
brancher un pc pas de sens faites ce que
vous voulez et après vous avez une
télécommande et vous pouvez utiliser
comme une petite télé vous avez vos
applications molotov disney plus netflix
donc pour les petits appartements il
vous faut une solution tout en un à la
fin pour travailler et à la fin pour le
divertissement c'est vraiment moniteurs
qui est au top aller à notre produit qui
est vraiment indispensable pour la
maison c'est un aspirateur connecter le
robot rock s est j'en utilise est plein
de produits drobo rock je devais avoir 4
5es est gilles à la maison en fait on
est tout le temps il marche très bien il
vibre aussi surtout le ménage vous avez
une application une fois de plus je vous
renvoie à ma vidéo on est quand même un
petit budget à un peu moins de 500 euros
mais pour vous solutionner toute la
question du ménage à la maison le 7 il
est top et puis aurait sur la la maison
connectée philips you phillip vous avez
beaucoup de choses vous allez avoir des
ampoules de lasbordes estrie des
filaments pour l'intérieur l'extérieur
bref c'est génial j'adore ça moi j'ai
aussi bien des ampoules connecté à la
maison j'ai des petites ampoules qui
vont dans des applis que je mangeais le
nom mais c'est pas grave je vais avoir
des petits bandeau lumineux va y en
avoir pour l'intérieur pour l'extérieur
et chantereine redécorer ici jean-paul
de partout du philip sion c'est toute la
maison qui en ellipse ou ici on a aussi
quand même plutôt pas mal je vous le
recommande j'aime beaucoup et ce que je
vais vous recommander également et bien
c'est un assistant vocal qui tient la
route alors moi je suis beaucoup google
avec nesta max parce que ça vous servira
à la fois pour surveiller votre maison
avec une petite caméra ça vous servira
également pour avoir et bien contrôler
grâce à votre écran notamment pour faire
revivre des photographes c'est un truc
qui est vraiment vraiment vraiment
génial le destin max on est à 229 euros
vous avez aussi les nestes audio j'en ai
positionner une là et puis là-bas le
qualité sonore est très cool et ça
fonctionne et puis là naissent de
rebelles pour la saône est de connecter
à la maison ça marche bien et si vous
êtes plutôt côté amazon alexa et bien
vous avez les cauchois disent je vous ai
également déjà présenté avec son écran
qui pivote tout seul je serais vraiment
vraiment bien donc voyez il ya plein de
produits y en a pour tout le monde des
smartphones des tablettes des écrans des
ac tion connecter des moniteurs des
casques il y en a pour la mobilité y en
a pour tout le monde vole un peu ma
sélection de fin d'année il a fallu
faire des choix il ya peut-être d'autres
produits j'aurais aimé vous présenter ou
mettre en avant mais regardez la dlg
jean galant même de tournage tout de
suite j'ai déjà 19 minutes c'est
beaucoup trop long donc on va couper
nous embrasse prenez soin de vous bonne
fin d'année à vous parce que je ne sais
pas qu'est ce que vous allez regarder
cette vidéo le soin de vous de votre
famille de proches et surtout profité
des fêtes de fin d'année et ça c'est
cool vous embrasse a très vite ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]